so
we've talked about Ivermectin
we've talked about people using iodine
sometimes sold under I guess it's like
the trade name Betadine
and now we have to talk about inhaling
hydrogen peroxide Vapor an article on
health.com
titled no inhaling hydrogen peroxide
Vapor to cure covet won't work
doctors warn please do not do this the
covid-19 pandemic has brought
questionable treatments it mentions
Ivermectin others are now reportedly
inhaling hydrogen peroxide
The Asthma and Allergy Foundation of
America released a warning this week
urging people not to try this dangerous
treatment Trend that's making the rounds
on social media some users claim that
putting hydrogen peroxide into a
nebulizer that's a breathing machine
that turns liquid asthma medication into
a mist and then breathing in the Mist
will help cure covet 19. many social
media sites are flagging and yanking
videos and claims but screenshots are
still showing up someone named Ryan
graney posted friends our vaccines will
no longer be valid on October 20th what
and Ivermectin will reign supreme they
are going to burn their damn lungs off
three percent food grade hydrogen
peroxide in a nebulizer or a small
syringe you can squirt it in your nose
add saline to it if it's too harsh the
Facebook post from a naturopathic doctor
suggests putting hydrogen peroxide in a
nebulizer for lung issues someone named
Dr Becky Campbell puts this is not
medical advice but did you know you can
put colloidal silver
and even hydrogen peroxide in a
nebulizer it can help your body fight
off pathogens systemically and can be
very effective this is another dangerous
unproven idea and we have a proven
approved vaccine
okay the aafa is practically begging
people to pass on this do not put
hydrogen peroxide into your nebulizer
and breathe it in this is dangerous it
is not a way to prevent nor treat covet
it is unclear where this originated
experts agree it's a really bad idea
look at this Jamie Allen PhD associate
professor of pharmacology and toxicology
at Michigan State says hydrogen peroxide
is a free radical
meaning it's an unstable atom that can
damage cells
if it's inhaled it goes to the lungs
where it can damage cell membranes it
can even get into the cells once the
cell membranes are compromised and can
damage DNA
if you inhale too much you can do major
damage to your lungs you can also
struggle with breathing normally and may
develop fluid in your lungs a condition
known as a pulmonary edema
amesh adalja MD scholar at John Hopkins
says I'm not even sure why people have
stumbled upon this there's no evidence
it can work to treat covet it can be
dangerous especially if you have
sensitive lungs hydrogen peroxide can
kill covet on surfaces but inhaling it
is a different story this is basically
like Trump's hit the body with an
injection of uh disinfectant right I
mean it's okay you might have a surface
and something can kill covet there
so what about putting it inside the body
as he likes to say doesn't apply doesn't
apply and it doesn't translate and again
part of this is just contrarianism
what I mean by that is they say I don't
know what's in the vaccine so I'm not
putting it in my body it hasn't been
studied enough so I'm not putting it in
my body but then they'll accept unknown
or at least in these contexts unstudied
substances
uh and really what it comes down to is
Biden's recommending the vaccine Biden's
not recommending hydrogen peroxide Vapor
or Ivermectin or Betadine iodine and its
contrarianism because they will accept
unknown or unstudied substances as long
as it's not the one a Democrat is
recommending but this is still the issue
of
they want to say you can't tell me what
to do
that's a you know they they claim that
the principles are unstudied don't know
what's in it chemicals Etc really the
prince the principle is you can't tell
me what to do I'm not going to follow
the medical advice of uh Public Health
officials or of doctors but then random
people on Facebook like this
naturopathic doctor with an inhaler
uh nebulizer says hey here's an idea not
medical advice but here's an idea of
something you can do and that they seem
to gladly be following this is a crisis
of Education this is a crisis of
critical thinking and if you are the
type of person
um who may even have compromised lungs
already and would be particularly at
risk by nebulizing hydrogen peroxide
really you should be vaccinated because
you're at risk of more serious covid
that's the bottom line we've said it a
million times I I how many more times
can I really repeat it uh I have a
feeling it'll probably be a few more
times